il marche le regard fier les
hom moi devant et eux derrière mes
hommes et si j'allonge le pas ils me
suivent pas à pas je ne leur échappe pas
mes hommes mes hommes ou que je sois ils
sont làes hommes je n'ai qu'attendre les
pour hommes je les regarde venir fiers
de leur m' parvenir c'est bon de les
voir sourir mes
hommes moi qui suis fille des Bru en
somme de la nuit de la lune tout
comme quand j'arrive le teint éclair moi
devant et derrière je comprends bien que
les gens s'étonnent s'étonnent car ils
viennent de Tunis mes
hommes Marseille tout long le midi mes
hommes il marchent avec insolence un
petit rien dans l' ça ressemble à une
danse mes
hommes il ne m'appelle pas Madame mes
hommes et tendrement il me nomme
patronne il se soumett à ma loi je me
soumets à leur loi que c'est dou d'obéir
à mes
hommes tout d'amour et de tendresse mes
h m'ont fait une forteresse mes hommes
non vous ne passerez pas ils sont
violents quelquefois c'est à eux n'y
touchez pas mes hommes mes hommes ils se
sont fait Sentinel mes
hommes il pourrait être cruel mes
hommes il me veille comme moi je les
veille quelquefois moi pour eu pour moi
mes homes enêtre les
premières quand le chagrin se fait lourd
mes hommes vont se re sans un mot debout
autour du piano et me disent tendrement
Pat paton c'est fou comme il
son quand le son du piano noir
ronne ils vont faire leur bagage on repr
le voyage pour qu'il voit du pays
[Musique]
so laissant la nuit furtive
mais de Lou s'esquive
personne ils vont chasser dans la nuit
berger gardz vos brebis qui ont le goût
et l'envie des hommes des hommes tard de
la blonde Rous mes hommes ils vont
coucher leur po douce mes hommes et
repartent dans la nuit courtoi mais pas
un tenderine quand ils ont croqué le
fruit la
comm ils reviennent au matin mes hommes
avec des fleurs dans les mains mes
hommes et reste là silencieux timide
bissant les yeux en attendant que je
leur
pardonne ils ont installé mon lit mes
hommes à l'ombre d'une prairie mes
hommes je veux m'endormir à l'ombre ils
y creuseront ma tombe pour la longue
nuit profonde et des hommes et des
hommes pr de fleur par une l mes
homm je n'ai pas le goût du Drome mes
hommes
continuez le regard fier je serai là
comme hier vous devant et moi derrière
je
[Musique]
met